the idea that more of a species makes it
a more successful species is only
relevant in a very limited biological
sense that the DNA of that species is
spreading in that sense that's success
but that says nothing about the
experience of individuals within that
speech-like and also the ten million
total species and how chickens and pigs
and cows are just getting slaughtered
right right and or more of them so they
must be better on people
educated clinicians who are working with
these issues believe that the human body
was not designed to last beyond 40
that's not true that is factually
incorrect and no one who understands
this data is is confused about this this
is an archaeologist anthropologist
they'd all understand this but when it
comes into popular culture it's a very
powerful idea because it feels good mmm
oh yeah we've done so well we've doubled
our lifestyle so whatever problems you
have you're not happy at work you feel
like your life is slipping away from you
you don't have any friends you're your
body's all messed up because this shitty
food that you're eating
look you're living twice as long the
sales pitch to get people to stop
complaining